well what about the Libertarian Party
can you tell us a little bit about what
it stands for Libertarian Party is based
on a firm principle of non-aggression we
all take a pledge when we join the party
that we will never initiate force
against somebody else that is you know a
pretty simple principle that everybody
should endorse it's a principle of what
makes civilization that is you respect
other people's life you respect other
people's property
thou shalt not steal and thou shalt not
murder it's it's that simple and most
everybody agrees to that and the next
question ought to be is worldwide is why
should you be different than Republican
Democrats if they tend to agree with
that same principle well we we believe
it's such an important moral principle
that if we can't take somebody else's
property and we can't hurt anybody or we
can't intimidate anybody or threaten the
use force we don't think the government
can either but we see the government as
the initiator of force to bring about
social and economic changes day in and
day out I mean they they may not come up
to our front door with a gun
occasionally they do but we know if we
don't deliver our money in our records
and do obediently what the government
wants in order to give up our portion of
our income through the Internal Revenue
Service the gun that will be quickly at
our door and we will be in prison so
it's the threat and the intimidation and
therefore they're transferring well
something that we can't do as
individuals so we as libertarians reject
this whole idea of forcible
redistribution of wealth which is the
welfare state same way in personal
liberties we apply this principle in the
area of personal liberties and although
I might want you and think you should
leave a certain lead a certain lifestyle
because I think it's good and light and
law I've no right to tell you what to do
you know if you want to live a certain
way I disagree that's that's tough you
know that's you're you're choosing
that's the individuals choice as long as
you don't hurt somebody else so the
person has the right to his own life and
his liberty his own lifestyle as with
one special rule that your lifestyle the
individual's lifestyle can't hurt
somebody else
so if you do things that I disapprove of
I as a libertarian
and tolerant and I accept that up and to
the point of no injury to anybody else
now I talk libertarians or listen to
them review them on TV and they're
talking about government power all the
time and abuse of governmental power but
I also see some libertarians not a whole
lot of them a lot of them also talk
about corporate power as well in other
words they're talking about power in
general there seem to be two types of
libertarians well I don't I don't find I
think we have one type of libertarian
because we all accept that the same
principle I think it's more easily found
that you have several types of
Republicans and several types of
Democrat because they're interventionist
and they can intervene any way they want
but I think libertarians are pretty
consistent in certainly condemning the
power of government I haven't heard a
libertarian saying that we need more
government or they're not a libertarian
but on the corporate power I think where
the confusion might come is corporate
size if its gained by serving the
consumer is not necessarily evil so if
if you have 90 percent of the car
industry for some miraculous reason for
some unknown reason there's no imports
if you have 90 percent of it that
doesn't bother me as a libertarian if
you have the best car the best price and
the consumers are very happy now if you
own if you have 90 percent or 100
percent of a utility company and you're
gouging the customers and the customers
have no place else to go we detest the
corporate size we detest corporate power
when it's gained through government
power you know government coercion if
it's a contract the military-industrial
complex is a pretty good example of how
large industries benefit by big
government of course in being a banking
big banks benefit by this monetary
system because they're sort of in
collusion with the Federal Reserve
System
so we detest that we detest bigness and
we detest corporate power when it's
gained through privilege from government
if corporations are large and there's
always free entry in a free market if
they're large because they serve the
consumer we don't worry too much about
that because we know the consumers
benefitting if they get to the point if
they had a hundred percent of an
industry which is not possible for free
market but they'd say just for instance
if a hundred percent and then they
started to gouge the people there would
immediately be competition the people
you know there has to be there always
has to be free entry and free
competition but there's nobody's ever
figured out where there's ever been a
true monopoly in a free market system -
all monopolies can be traced to some
form of government protectionism well of
course now we talk about the government
and corporations but as you've set up at
the top they're all the same people the
corporate executives go to and from the
government they hold positions in the
government the people from the
Trilateral Commission and the
Bilderbergers and all they're all
corporate people and they have their
relationships and interlocks with the
banks and with universities and
foundations and all that so to talk
about one so you're really talking about
one source of power instead of
corporation on one side and government
on the earlier because it's all one pot
as you said I think it's become one pot
knowing that is you don't have any help
I say voting for a Democrat who may be a
little more critical of large
corporations but we know Democrats are
just as much in bed with big government
- I mean you take a michael dukakis for
instance do you think maybe Boston there
was a somewhat dependent on some
military contracts Kip O'Neil
I mean they're just as much it's all
demagoguery when it comes to these
political campaigns so either side
they're the same people control it and
you know Ronald Reagan spoke sharply
against the Trilateral Commission but he
was the first president to host the
Trilateral Commission in the White House
I mean that's how blatant it is it says
it's the same group of people that's why
you find no political action committee
no large corporation who supports
libertarians I voted while in Congress I
think the the the strictest free-market
set of votes ever but I never got
political action committee money but
small business people who want to
compete against big business they're
their free market people
they're much more likely to be
libertarians and believe in the
principles of free enterprise but once
the corporation get real large and
they're more interested in paying a
couple hundred thousand dollars for a
top lobbyist who knows the system who
can get a regulation that exempts their
corporation or gets their contract in
place and this this is the way the
system works so we reward the lobbyists
of the political action committees much
more so than we reward a principle of
freedom what about this banking and
currency committee and we've had
congressman Gonzalez on it was one of
your colleagues and he sees the world
very clearly and sees the power
structures at work and I'm sure you have
a clear picture of this also is this one
of the reasons you became a libertarian
instead of a Republican well it's
certainly one of the reasons why I got
involved in politics because I was very
fascinated with economics in particular
particularly monetary policy and if you
think about it money is pretty important
if you look at all transactions whether
you're buying something or selling your
services one-half of all economic
transaction is the monetary unit so if
somebody has control over the value of
the monetary unit they control every
transaction therefore if you have an
institution such as a government
ordained bank like a central bank like
our Federal Reserve if they have
absolute monopoly control over the value
of that currency they control everything
in economy it becomes a form of a
government regulated economy it doesn't
become socialism but the money obviously
is socialistic in that the government
controls it so they increase the supply
the value goes down if they tighten the
supply interest rates go up so it's
tremendous economic power in the
insiders those who know what the policy
is literally can benefit they don't
stuff their pockets and line their
pockets with cash that's not the way it
happens but those who are in the inside
and knowledgeable will benefit because
they know which direction interest rates
are going in which way the economy is
going and if you look at the members of
the Federal Reserve you find out
that they don't ask people like me to be
on the Federal Reserve even though I've
had experience on studying the issue and
been on the bank committee they ask only
the people who are casually referred to
as the insiders those from Wall Street
and the banking industry the poll
Volkers and the Alan Greenspan is on the
world they're on the inside they know
how to deal with the establishment and
they get these positions and therefore
it is a tremendous amount of economic
power falls into the hands of what we
call the Open Market Committee the
Federal Open Market Committee they
control from day to day the supply money
they become the legal Konnor fitters you
know if you and I had controlled the
printing press we could do a lot of a
lot of things you know self-serving
that's what happens when the politicians
create the central bank that get that to
control the money now this control of
central bank and the money goes on
regardless of which party is in power
right it never changes you know they
change a person here and there but it's
always the insiders it's always from the
same group so if you have a Republican
as president or the Democrats they're
going to get the same appointments
appointments never change then this can
be said about the Secretary of State and
the Secretary of Defense and the
Secretary of Treasury and in the Federal
Reserve Board members they all come from
the same group and even though I guess
naively I was hopeful that the same
group of individuals would not have as
much power under our under Ronald Reagan
but you know I was there I witnessed and
of course that led to my disenchantment
my disappointment enough to the point
where I just said I've had enough and
then I left the Republican Party and
joined the libertarian party with the
idea that you cannot trust Republicans
to be independent of the system either
although Ronald Reagan led us to believe
that he would be independent record for
civil liberties for the libertarians to
my mind is very good and even I think it
was the last interview we did with a
libertarian County for president said he
would Bala SH the CIA the FBI and
the IRS do you hold the same position
yes I do
because you know most of our history we
didn't didn't have those institutions
the FBI came in during the First World
War and interestingly enough one thing
that Woodrow Wilson did he used the FBI
to spy on American citizens and actually
arrests them if they disagreed with his
foreign policy about going to war in
Europe and is it an interesting how
recent they used it in the Vietnam era
Democrats used their Republicans used
the FBI to spy on a hundred different
groups in this country including the
churches who disagree with the policy in
Central America it almost looks like the
FBI was designed to spy on Americans who
might be disagreeing with policy
especially the foreign policy so the FBI
although I don't think I could condemn
everything they've ever done because I'm
sure some of the investigations and
investigation of crime has been
beneficial but that could be
accomplished through Justice Department
within our state's we wouldn't reject
that portion of it I think the FBI has
kept and continues to keep a lot of
records on a lot of individuals the CIA
has only been here since 1947 their
record is lousy you just think of the
CIA used by the Democratic
administration to murder diem and
escalate the war in Vietnam and here we
have a Republican using the CIA to sell
weapons to the Ayatollah to raise funds
dealing drugs go to Central America
fight wars that have not been approved
by the people or the Congress so we see
the CIA is very very detrimental
skirting the law and here we had Casey
proposing a super CIA he thought there
was too much control over the CIA that
existed that congressman now
occasionally asked questions and they
don't ask enough so they were talking
about a super CIA the CIA II was used in
a bad policy in in Cuba we think that
intelligence gathering is permissible to
defend this country but up until 1947
that was done as a military operation if
you needed to know whether there were
troops massing for an invasion that the
CIA ought to know about
we ought to know get that information
now have that intelligence but now in
this age especially in the modern age I
mean we don't even need to have somebody
over in Europe or in the Soviet Union we
don't even need to send powers in an
airplane every year we have satellites
you can practically watch an individual
walking around on the street
with the technology available so I would
say even modern technology is a
absolutely moved us into an age where we
ought to become more modern and get away
from this CIA operative snooping around
actually causing a lot more trouble than
good that include all these
interventions and covert actions and
surrogate mercenaries which were using
than Sam so American absolutely we would
do away with that but that doesn't mean
that we would complacently say that we
shouldn't have a national defense if
we're concerned about the spread of
communism one of the first things we as
libertarians would do would be to stop
the funding of the Communists you know
we're still sending money to the
Communists increase that under the
Reagan administration is unbelievable
what we've been but we've been doing but
if there is a threat to our national
security
rather than using these secretive
operatives going around and murdering
and picking and choosing our personal
dictators that serve our banking and
business interests it should be done so
through the Congress Congress should
know about it it's the people's money
and it's the kids lives that are being
dealt with so therefore it should be
open if our national security is
threatened Congress oughta have a vote
on it never secretly with the power of a
president to wage war that's a very
dangerous thing to happen some
libertarians are against the public
school system they would close down the
public school system do you think this
is a good thing or do you believe in
there well I I don't think the public
school system has a real good record I
think the educational quality is very
very low in getting lower all the time I
think that you can go to some of the big
cities and you find out that it's the
schools are drug infested and
crime-infested and there's violence and
very little education more than a
million kids drop out a year before they
get their high school diploma it's an
armed fortress and so we think the
record is very
we have concern about good education and
of course we want to go in the direction
of privatizing all schools but in the
very practical world of politics
I don't think its rise for me to say
that tomorrow we could have private
schools I don't think it's likely to
happen so we can do a whole lot set our
ideals work toward it and we can change
the whole I think where we really have
gone astray has been in this century
where we have gotten in in probably the
last three or four years when we got the
federal government involved and the
local governments have been involved in
schools most of our history and I think
if we had the federal government out of
it in the state governments and schools
were controlled locally although that
wouldn't be perfect libertarianism it
would be a far cry better than what we
have but even short of doing all that we
as libertarians would really promote a
little competition we don't like
monopolies when they're government
monopolies because that's really the
only government only monopoly you get
but a monopoly of her school system is a
great danger so we would immediately
introduce the idea and we think it would
help the school right off that is allow
tax credits or vouchers for people who
one prayer in the school how can we
force people in prayer in school and you
know that's a violation of civil
liberties but what we could do is say if
you don't like the way your kids are
being taught let's allow you to have
competition let's give you a tax credit
or a voucher and go down the street and
have the kind of school you want so we
would want competition that to me would
be a practical alternative and moving in
the right direction I guess the most
controversial stand which libertarians
have now is on drugs you probably get a
lot of criticism because you want to
legalize the drugs right well but I
think the most controversial thing about
the whole drug problem is is even
coloring that's that's what's
controversial this idea that we have no
privacy there's no financial privacy or
privacy in our home because the Drug
Enforcement Agency can break our doors
down looking for a cigarette but they
confiscate cars and boats and houses are
bulldozed in all in the name of
of teaching people not to have bad
habits they're spending 10 billion
dollars I think it's an incredible
program of failure so the controversy is
really in the hands of the government
Democrats and Republicans who are saying
the same thing in each party tries to
outdo the other and they're actually
absolutely obsessed with this at the
same time they care not a litte about
you know our civil liberties the drug
laws I've only been here since 1914
about that time we had the income tax
the federal reserve system the FBI
licensing to protect certain industries
and professions then we decided we're
going to tell people how to live and
what their habits ought to be that's
when they introduced the ideas of
prohibition of alcohol didn't work very
well
and so that was finally repealed
libertarians detest drug dealers that's
one reason why we want to get rid of the
laws we want to get the drug dealer out
of business overnight because he can't
exist unless the drug price is very high
so a lot of good people inadvertently
are the allies of the drug dealers if
they like the drug laws the people who
write those laws and like those laws
inadvertently promote crime every drug
addict because he has to pay these
exorbitant amounts for their drugs
commit on the average 260 felonies a
year to raise the money and we'd be
totally on this set who raises that kind
of money to go buy a 6-pack at the
drugstore
no I have to do that because the
alcohols available now the hawk kills
more people than drugs cigarettes they
kill three hundred and twenty five
thousand people a year and waterway
required to subsidize tobacco industry
you have people want to really do good
that's just quick - subsidizing tobacco
get the government out of the sale of
alcohol and and go that way but the
crime rate would go down the drug
dealers would be out of business I think
the kids wouldn't be as exposed either
it's pretty hard to tell a kid that's
just dropped out of a public school
where he was totally bored and he's on
the street court decides he wants a job
and buy a car talk them into working at
McDonald's know what else
he can make $400 a day doing a little
work for the local drug merchants
there's no way he's tempted and he
yields to the temptation so we literally
set the stage by these drug laws to get
more kids involved and I think that's
horrible I think the kids have to they
certainly deserve some protection we
deserve at least to create an
environment where they're not so likely
to be forced into the drug trade now
you're a medical doctor and you think
that legalizing all these drugs would be
good does the do your medical colleagues
and the medical profession they agree
with this no to a minority matter of
fact I think that even drugs for
treating oneself should be more readily
available to people not I think people
should do it unwisely and use a lot of
fancy medication without some advice but
if drugs were more available you know if
a nurse could prescribe penicillin it
certainly would be a lot cheaper nurses
are capable of telling you whether you
have a strep throat or not we drive the
cost down so doctors have a little
protectionism involved they like their
little monopolies of the AMA and Iraq
the AMA lobbied be in Washington to vote
against even allowing doctors to get
heroin for dying cancer patients who
couldn't have their pain relief from
morphine but they were they they did not
want this to happen because it didn't
want they wanted to have control they
didn't look like they were soft on drugs
but they want control so whether it's
the drugs necessary right now the FDA I
think is as a horrible disservice to us
all by making it very difficult for aids
and cancer patients to do alternative
treatments you know they're smuggling
drugs from Mexico you know we think of
Mexico as a socialist state and yet they
can get drugs more readily there and
we're having dying cancer patient they
in patients smuggling drugs up into the
free United States in order for them to
take this medicine but FDA argues well
we got to make sure it's safe and
effective well if somebody's dying don't
you think they have the right to take a
chance on a drug an experimental drug
but the AMA isn't helpful in here in the
medical profession is very poor a lot of
doctors would agree with me but I think
they like the idea that they're sort of
godlike and they get to write
descriptions and they certainly think
that opening up this whole better also
to speak would be detrimental to their
protection in their they're interested
in organized medicine what about the
police and law enforcement professional
would they be for your point of view it
would put a lot of them out of work I
think a lot of would make a lot less
money you know it's their system has
been corrupted by oh gosh it's a you
know another example of how fully some
of these laws are is they the prisons
are running rampant with drugs if we
can't keep drugs out of the prison how
are we going to keep drugs off the
street which means it's very very much a
corrupting influence I mean we we read
stories I'm sure the majority of the
police are not involved but you don't
need very many to really make a lot of
money off it so there are going to be
some officials who would agree with us
and I've had some I had there was an
interesting story of an individual my
staff went to work for a candidate who
was running for governor ship in a large
city and they brought all the district
attorneys together because crime was the
number one issue in that state and they
made them there they said that the only
way you could ever get rid of crime
would be and they all agreed on this is
you'd have to get rid of the drug law so
behind closed door without depressed
they agreed the drug laws created a
crime and you know what they said you
can't ever achieve that because there
are too many people on the take too many
judges and policemen like this so just
forget about it we can't deal with it
it's too much of an emotional issue
anyway but it is an important issue I
think the discussion has progressed a
whole lot in the last six months I think
we as libertarians have done a whole lot
of good in getting this discussion out
and I am going to continue to debate
this because as a parent of five
children and as a physician as a non
drug user I think that I have some
credibility in making this debate on the
idea that drugs ought to be
decriminalized let's talk about what
could be the most explosive issue of
this campaign if the mass media would
get a hold up and do something about it
but they're covering it up
and that is the you were talking about
the government involvement in drugs
there have been government
investigations there have been private
investigations and we've interviewed a
lot of people but the ex-cia people who
have talked about the CIA involvement
and drug operations for many decades
it's public knowledge so once again the
media are not saying thing about it that
Oliver North and his people involved
with the Contras have been running drug
operations cocaine primarily bringing it
back into the United States and there
are other investigations which show that
George Bush's office Donald Gregg
particularly in the people he was
working with have been supervising an
enormous drug operation which once again
was bringing sending illegal arms or
down to the Contras and elsewhere and
bringing cocaine and other types of
drugs back into the United States but
neither the Democrats aren't talking
about this now are the libertarians
talking about this and did they put this
into the framework of the drug law
situation that you're talking about we
talk about a whole lot of course we
always have the trouble of getting the
attention that we think it deserves
there have been a few Democrats have
talked about Senator Kerry's office I
heard some work he's gone in love the
investigation right and I think he's on
to something and I think we've gotten
some other information too of course
that George or the CIA has given the
Noriega over the years $200,000 a year
oh yes and they kept feeding him money
even when Bush was the head of the CIA I
think George Bush is deep into it well
over this head somebody asked me once of
if I thought George Bush knew about as
much what's going on this as Ronald
Reagan I think George Bush knew a lot
more about what was having the CIA
because I think Reagan was probably more
removed from it I mean just by his own
personality and maybe his age or
something but I think George Bush
through his office and through the fact
that he was a member of this you know
head of the CIA I think he was very very
close to it he know
exactly what was happening and I believe
the rule that once the CIA member always
a CIA member and I think it's awful
interesting can you imagine it would
alarm a few of us in this country if all
of a sudden we knew that the leader in
the Soviet Union would be the head KGB
agent here we take our head CIA agent
and put them you know potentially in the
head of our entire country unfortunately
I wish that we could get this
information out and I continue to talk
about it but I sadly believe that there
will be very little said which means
that the Democrats aren't doing it that
means they're involved here involved I
don't think there's any doubt about it I
mean it was there even some of it got
reported in the iran-contra scandals we
did know that there were drugs being
drugs involved and and they were selling
drugs back and forth I think that might
be the number one reason for the drug
laws I mean they use and play on the
good people of America to support them
but I think the number one reason is not
not to have high prices for some two-bit
drug dealer as much as to raise the
funds necessary to for governments to do
illegal things whether it's some
terrorist government someplace or
whether it's our own CIA to fund
programs that they can't get Congress to
fund
I think it's tragic and the sooner we
get rid of the drug laws the sooner this
would end there is a great push now for
some type of national health service
national health care the United States
is the only Western capitalist country
outside of South Africa if you consider
that an advanced Western capitalist
country which doesn't have some type of
comprehensive health care system are the
libertarians for this are they against
it well we're for we're for a
comprehensive health care system and we
want everybody to have major medical
coverage and the best insurance and the
best medical care
that's why medical care has to be
delivered by the free market if we don't
care about medical care and quality if
we like lines and if you like the
medical care the Indians get and if
you're happy
the Veterans Hospital if you're happy
with how England runs things in the
Soviet Union and I guess we need another
move in the direction of socialized
medicine government now even though we
don't have a a major national program
government now delivers 60% of the
healthcare in this country the more we
spend the higher the costs the lower the
quality less people who get the care I
mean it's a lousy delivery system poor
people who can buy their TVs and cars
and video cassette recorders have no
health care they buy the VCRs and their
televisions and the cars in the
marketplace they get their healthcare
through government program with all the
spending there are still 38 million
people who have no insurance whatsoever
just devising and they get another
government program which won't work but
just further push up costs and put
controls and more doctors dropping out
and I think it is a total disaster if
it's a national health program run by
the government
it's tragic it won't work it's going to
ruin the care in the country if we care
about people we will have a national
health care program but it will be
delivered by the free market but the
free market is what we have now we have
bad health care we have a greater
percentage of GNP being spending on
health care than those places in those
countries where they have the government
Fiat I don't agree I don't think that we
have free market medicine as I said that
60% is paid by government we have
coercive rules that force governments
into these HMO organizations government
you know the large companies had to
offer these things so they've been
growing and now going bankrupt and when
you pump a lot of money in if
government's paying the bills through
Medicare or Medicaid this doesn't spread
the money out a lot of wealthy people
get to benefits the poor people don't
seem to get through the you know the
maze of papers but a lot of millionaires
receive Medicare benefits so they get
their Hospital pay payments but when
they go in and pay and have a little
insurance what happens the hospitals and
the doctors in the labs tend to you know
jack up the prices so and then the
government has to come in and say what
we're going to put on controls because
the prices are too high and then we're
going to ration care so one problem
leads
leads to the next but the problems you
see today I result of 50 years of
ever-increasing government intervention
in medicine the the government doesn't
pays for 60% of our automobiles you know
but they pay for 60% of our medical care
the automobile prices are high but
they're not as high proportionately
speaking cost of automobiles going up at
the rate of about four or five percent a
year the cost of medical care is going
up about 15 or 20 percent governments in
in education they're in college
education are always subsidizing college
education always the guy that doesn't
get to go to college has to subsidize
the guy that gets to go cost of
education is going up about 15 to 20
percent so as soon as you get government
involved quality does not go up but the
cost goes up and there's not any fairer
distribution where do you stand on the
the right-to-lifers and those folks like
you the anti-abortion people like the
libertarian hits mixed they like me
because I'm a right to life liberty
Rhian I believe killing a fetus is an
act of aggression I've been forced to be
in a room unfortunately when I saw a
three pound fetus the infant taken out
breathing and crying and thrown in a
bucket I mean I took my I take my plate
seriously I mean that to me look like an
act of aggression besides if I get the
wrong medication as a physician to a
mother and I damage the fetus the fetus
when it's born can sue me obviously it
was legal alive inhuman or couldn't be
able to wouldn't be able to sue me I
know the fetus determines its
inheritance rights at the time of
conception so I mean I I'm in
disagreement with our platform but there
were enough libertarians who agree with
my position that I went on the first
ballot at our convention the truth is
it's a difficult issue and nobody likes
to think about it because the way the
law states now under Roe vs. Wade the
fetus one second before birth the weight
of nine pounds still has no legal rights
and nobody enjoys defending that
position very difficult because I as a
libertarian I don't like to interfere
with the privacy of a woman either but
how are we going to deal with this I
think we have to have respect for human
life or we can't have respect for
individual liberty and the right to
smoke a cigarette so you think the
government government has the right to
force a woman to carry a fetus full-term
then I think the government has the
right to protect life I sort of like
saying if the baby is born in the IQ is
65 and they won at a hundred does the
government have the right to force that
person not to kill their baby yes I do
think so I think the government has a
right to protect life but the government
doesn't have the right to force anything
so it's a it is difficult obviously but
I think the bottom line is is killing a
fetus and act of aggression and the only
way the libertarians or others who
disagree with me on that would they
would have to say that no it's obviously
an act of aggression there's no debate
there it's that the fetus is not a
person the penis isn't not alive and
it's not human and I as a physician had
a lot of trouble with that I mean I know
it's alive I know it's you and I know
it's legal so this is very unique you
know I don't advocate any federal laws I
don't you know we libertarians nor this
system that we have advocated federal
laws to deal with theft or murder or
anything you know it's all handled by
the state so I think that the states
would handle it differently I think
courts would handle it differently I
think juries would handle it differently
but I think under my ideal situation we
wouldn't have people having abortion on
demand and using it as birth control and
having a callous attitude about life and
instead of having less illegitimate
pregnancies or births illegitimate or
unwanted pregnancies now it actually it
was intended to help difficult
situations but when it has done is that
the teenager sometimes can have three
abortions in a year which is sad and
into tragedy and I've seen tragedies
I've witnessed them and I have great
empathy for them but I also have great
respect for the principles of freedom
and I don't want to infringe or
compromise my concept of what it Liberty
is what's the libertarian solution to
the farm problem just free-market remark
and get the government out of it
you know under Ronald Reagan the
subsidies in 1980 were ten billion
dollars a year they've gone up to 26
billion dollars a year and there's just
as many bankruptcies as ever
prices are wildly fluctuating as ever I
think it'd be much better if we got rid
of all the subsidies and gave the
farmers steady prices and a sound dollar
low interest rates prices it didn't jump
all over the place which is a reflection
of the dollars value rather than just
commodity values obviously when there's
a drought prices are going to fluctuate
more than others but this whole idea
that when farmers produce too much we're
supposed to subsidize them when there's
a drought and they produce too little
we're supposed to subsidize them and now
I hear there's a early frost coming now
they're gonna have to be bailed out for
the early frost you know first it's
overproduction and then there's a
drought and then there's an early frost
I think the idea is wrong I think it's
bad economics and morally it's it's
wrong I mean I'm having a bad year this
year in medicine I mean should I ask you
to be taxed so that you can send me some
money
because I'm having a bad medical year or
somebody else has a business it doesn't
do well sure you can have sympathy that
is your friend or relative you can help
him if you want but the able to coerce a
non farmer to pay him because he needs
something or once something violates all
concept of rights nobody can demand
something and call it a right everybody
has a right to their life in their
liberty but they don't have a right to
somebody else's property and they can't
use the government to coerce in order to
get it if you became president would you
abolish the Federal Reserve or try to
dance it's a constitutional question
also well and try to break the power of
the banking system in the country we'd
get rid of the Federal Reserve but
unfortunately it is a constitutional
question but it shouldn't be he the
founders were rather clear they say they
authorized no central bank they said we
could not emit Bills of credit which is
paper money they said the only gold and
silver could be legal tender and the
only monetary function that the Congress
had was to mint gold and silver coins
so if we'd fall DaCosta to
we would not have a central bank and we
would not have a Fiat paper currency we
would have a gold or silver standard or
both we believe that we should have
honest money which is a commodity
standard we don't liam in counterfeiting
we don't believe the individual can
counterfeit paper and give it to people
say this is money of real value but we
don't think the politician and the
Federal Reserve can do that either we
get rid of the Federal Reserve and we
think it would not only help the economy
what it would do is would help the
people because the people would save
their money again prices would be lower
interest rates would be lower and we'd
eliminate the business cycle so the
sooner we get rid of the Federal Reserve
the better what would you do about the
deficit that's enormous def modesto we
have the deficit should be eliminated by
one technique cutting spending
you can't cut spending until we decide
as a people what we want from our
government we want welfare and warfare
the budget will never be balanced we're
gonna have an economic calamity is going
to be very very major if we want some
sense to our government we should
balance the budget we should do it
immediately and it should be done by
cutting and it should be cut both
domestically and internationally we
certainly can cut military spending
because a lot of the military spending
has nothing to do with national defense
we do not have to sacrifice defense
I believe we changed our policy we could
have a better defense but we would spend
a lot less money especially overseas
same way at home it's too much welfare
we cut back on welfare it's too much
interest on the national debt
a sound currency would lower the
interest payment so we would balance the
budget and media at a much lower level I
think it would be the greatest thing in
the world for the economy you have a
last statement you'd like to make for
our viewers yes I would like to suggest
to the viewers that you should look at
your choices I think this year you do
have a choice I think it's foolish to
waste your vote voting Republican voting
Democrat is a pure waste of your vote so
if you want to vote for less government
if you want to say you're not satisfied
with a status quo then you have to vote
libertarian if you stay at home which
many people are doing their standing at
home these days because they are
disgusted like we are but they don't
think as much worth much chance of
changing things
but if you vote Republican or Democrat
it makes no difference whatsoever if
they like what they have they're
satisfied with the status quo doesn't
matter but if you don't want to waste
your vote if you want to make your vote
productive make your vote count
come join the libertarians vote
libertarians send the message because
even if we get 5 or 10 or 15 percent of
the vote we will revolutionize politics
in this country for the next hundred
years and that's what we want to do we
want to set the stage for the 1990s when
the libertarian party can be a
predominant force in this country